[Music]
Comcast there will come a day young
people that you will look upon these
minions like a walk span you will rue
the day you made them popular irritation
irritation opening shots of New York
landmarks tell me this is going to be
universals first kid-friendly animated
Apocalypse movie here's the camera
panning up the Brooklyn Bridge and oh
look right crossed the way is the Empire
State Building exactly how I remember
New York I've lived in this city all my
life k-9 narration she was looking for a
roommate and so was I Katy throws her
opportunity to split expensive New York
City rent in the ship by adopting a doll
I'm willing to overlook the fact that he
ate this ridiculous number of shoes
because dog be crazy but what I can't
overlook is a king walk-in closet in a
Manhattan apartment Jesus movie we get
it even Woody Allen doesn't romanticize
New York this much Kati repeats an
insult she's presumably heard many times
on the city streets even though it's
clearly cold enough for Katy to wear a
jacket and a scarf most of what we're
gonna see in this movie is spring or
fall and Katy's winter wear is a lie hey
max it's less amazing to me that dogs
can talk to each other in this movie
than it is that two New Yorkers left
their windows wide open while away from
the house I mean the fire escape is
right in there
hey know all that blind would do is go
down farther and even if it did go back
up it would irritatingly stop at the
halfway point in the window also did
this guy not take his dog out this
morning mostly I'm noticing a pattern if
these owners being horrible everyone in
this goddamn building leaves for work at
the exact same time in the morning
aren't there any unemployed slackers or
nightshift workers or youtubers around
to witness the daily peda Palooza also
everyone in this building seems to own a
pet is it a requirement on the
application whoa what the hell is runty
doing in that cage oh yeah sure he's
running mm-hmm this is a cute shout-out
but why would a bird owner have a giant
poster of the movie that had everyone
freaked the hell out about Bert's does
he have a pro Demick poster in his
bedroom this cat is capable of opening a
refrigerator which has this giant handle
on it that would require acrobatics this
fat cat is not capable of not to mention
having to jump on the counter to reach
it in the first place who leaves a whole
goddamn chicken exposed in the fridge
and are you telling me this never
happened before this cat's owner is the
most oblivious person who ever walked
this earth did she spend all that time
preparing and cooking it last night
think you know what I'd rather have
pizza then throw that hole in the ice
books so far we've seen all kinds of
animals make messes break into
appliances rub their asses on the floor
over PA the flower pot and generally put
things the secret the movies selling
here is that pets are really dicks you'd
be a good boy Leonard this appears to be
playing on an iPod of some sort so who
bought this song so the dogs can rock
out also we've gotten into some serious
Toy Story level bullish beer where
supposedly these animals have been able
to do everything in secret without
someone walking in unexpectedly in
exposing their hidden lifestyles is
nobody could ever love a cat the way
they love a dog that's cat cyst Chloe
could have come through the several
windows that are wide open but chooses
to squeeze her fat ass through this one
that's partially closed so how did you
know you were in the sky when you were
in the baggage area buddy Jesus Christ
she doesn't even lock the front door
this is New York City I'm going
to start calling this dog Buzz Lightyear
I have no idea why look just go with it
this is Duke he's going to be your
brother he should probably spend less
time collecting dogs and focus on
actually getting that roommate maybe we
could share somehow through animated
proportional curry this movie is going
to show that this dog can possibly fit
in this bed
he stole my weight if the language the
dogs used to communicate with each other
just sounds like barking to humans then
why don't they do it all the time this
isn't a secret life after all and if
it's gonna come down to you or me it's
gonna be me
you see if this conversation involved a
bunch of barking which is how it would
sound to Katie she would have come to
see what the problem was right Katie has
no clue about this new dog whether he's
housebroken if he chews on stuff if he's
gonna kill max but leaves without taking
any precautions I can't tell whether
katie is just blissfully clueless or
consistently high are every one of these
vent flaps missing proper screws so that
this guinea pig can crash into every
apartment and the last time we saw
Norman he was in a duct that was near
the ceiling so what kind of ventilation
system does this apartment building half
where it has floor and ceiling shafts
Katie positions this end table like
three feet away from the couch or chair
making reaching the remote impossible
and it may be the narrowest highest end
table I've ever seen hey this is the
least believable scene in the movie
where a group of dogs walk straight down
a sidewalk without all of them running
in separate directions to smell
something also why is Max's leash so
much longer than the other dogs
hey the power of boners will cause the
chain reaction for this animated
adventure to finally adventure oh my
gosh what happened to you
all right I wish this movie would
explain how humans can't hear what the
pets are saying but dogs and cats and
guinea pigs and hawks share the exact
same language there was an argument
between the director and the animators
on enough cats also I know they're
supposed to be alley cats but this is
ridiculous why would they just appear
out of nowhere to defend this asshole
epic cats ever been interested in
solidarity also some of these cats are
hiding in clothes hanging on these wires
which is funny but then you have to
imagine a cat gripping those clothes
from the inside for hours without
getting uncomfortable cats don't do
uncomfortable that guy
Duke smartly escapes this situation but
doggy CK decides to stick around and try
some new material in the horde of
deranged cats right has anyone ever seen
these dedicated animal control officers
who only appear in movies
since when do they patrol the streets
like cops looking for running animals
and this guy is obviously derelict in
his duty because the alley next door is
a cesspool of cats main characters
trapped in a vehicle driving right past
where they're supposed to be cliche
these animals are trying to break out
this big dog that's on the truck so I'm
wondering how they knew the truck was
going to be here at this very moment
Animal Control guy continues to drive
even though the threat he's running from
is in the car with him more door opening
shenanigans from the animals in this
movie who obviously consulted finding
Dory for all the door opening happening
in this movie carrot key also a carrot
key that doesn't break immediately when
trying to turn it in this metal lock
accurate depiction of Manhattan driving
movie goes to suicide squad Ian levels
to force me to say they all survive this
does every movie apartment rooftop have
a shed where someone keeps birds
Tiberius went through this whole ruse to
get Gidget to unlock his cage and take
his head off but he didn't notice he was
chained to the shed this whole
time I don't know it's more annoying
that there are several unnecessary
vignettes in this movie that Gidget
happens to be involved in almost all of
them this is as good a time as any to
ask how snowball can live in the sewer
yet remain brilliantly white just give
him the password dude I mean
surely there are a million white bunnies
that look exactly like you so shouldn't
you get mad if they don't ask you for
the password
oh hey kind of like that movie flushed
away that nobody saw so it can be easily
copied without anyone noticing yeah but
how does this work
yep natural predators and prey all
living together but they all get along
do they only feed on rival rats from
right
you can't hurt someone what a spoon says
the guy who just fashioned a key out of
a carrot right key even in cartoons even
in the sewer even with a bunch of
animals they somehow found a way to
overdose on candle usage humans on sight
so if the flushed pets are literally
about a war against humans why don't
they kill more humans
sounds like Ricky was the only one even
though they have a crocodile in their
army also this underground introduction
to a resistance fighters scene is a
little more demolition man than I think
they intended how was the kids parties
but then bunny tricks will not stop so
is this set in the 1960s Tiberius was
out looking for Max and had no clue
about his backstory just as description
so how and why did he capture one of the
alley cats even if there were a way that
the cat actually knew who and where the
flush pets were max just got there like
an hour ago so there's no way he could
have gotten that Intel so quickly
initiating a couple aspects domestics
those two in the early /do off the
towers yeah but all these members used
to be domestics right there called the
flushed pets who cares that Max
and Duke were just recently caught by
animal control they would have no reason
to believe they didn't just abandon
their owners what is this thing holding
up this pile of bricks in a sewer what's
its function you squished the sack
did you not see what
happened I mean a resounding no is the
answer to that stupid question you might
actually deserve this this might be
something that was long overdue
not on my watch way too much of letting
Kevin Hart do this you know this movie
really hasn't earned the burgeoning max
Duke friendship
they were assholes to each other in the
first 30 minutes of the movie and
basically just met max was addicted Duke
on the first night Duke became an even
bigger dick then max became even bigger
dick than Duke I haven't seen them have
one conversation together yet that
didn't involve hating each other or
being dicks but now we're rooting for
them to escape why Duke Mario is a
turtle and then goes into a pipe where
he'll most likely warp to a later level
we're sorry
max summarizes my feelings about
watching this movie when I got my claws
caught in the curtains who pulled me
down max did there's a supreme level of
story missing from this movie to make
any of this feel right max is basically
the hero of this apartment building but
we've never seen him do anything heroic
we're only hearing about it just now
remember Toy Story the movie this movie
wants to be Woody is established early
on as the leader and favorite we root
for him because it looks like he cares
about the rest of the toys and treats
them with respect but max has done
nothing to Annette and that random cat
tried to eat sweet Pete who saved him it
wasn't a random cat it was you how come
every animal in this movie can talk
except for Sweet Pea Max and Duke
attended the Jim Gordon school of
escaping sewers it appears we've now hit
the x mark and a portion of the film
everything will now be something saves
Max and Duke at the last minute kind of
things somewhere in New York there's got
to be at least one asshole who just saw
two dogs jump on a ferry and saw one dog
throw a life preserver out to save the
other dog and videoing it and that video
would be on YouTube getting
gangnam-style views sigh snowball only
the protagonists will escape via the
unguided sewage pipe that's piping
sewage directly into the East River
wiener dog using its long body to climb
things couldn't be more toy if its story
movie does this for a second time you
saw it in the trailers you saw it at the
beginning of this movie now where do we
go is it still funny for a movie that
likes animals so much you'd think they'd
stop beating a dead horse this is pops
place this owner is never home so it's
kind of a hot spot his owner is never
home so who feeds him and takes him out
even if he's hired someone to do it this
would happen two to three times a day
right cuz that noise movie this dog is
even wearing training wheels and nobody
comes to check on him there are some
true asshole pet owners in this flick I
do know a guy in the shoe in the film
makers saw a 30-second clip of Dana
Carvey doing his back in my day SNL bit
on YouTube and said sold so where are
you from my fuzzy age dude I'm a cat
well nobody's perfect
movie feels to cite some like it hot for
the line it just did also yeah the cat
would be amazing at cinema since sausage
because we needed one more way for max
and Duke to get hilariously distracted
from their journey home also let's think
about this after Katie left for work max
and Duke trashed the apartment while
waiting for the dog walker to come we
can assume that was mid-day because
Katie probably took them out in the
morning since that time they've walked
to the park escaped got into an alley
cat fight or abducted escaped again
after snowflake crashed the car went
through the whole initiation process
escaped again then took a
all the way to Brooklyn my point is Kati
is knocking home yet to discover them
missing this whole gang is able to John
McLean themselves up into the ventilator
shaft both birds are screaming here is
they descent I guess it's because they
conveniently forgot to have the goddamn
power of flight today's top video is a
cat doing impossible cat things while
being filmed by a dog who is apparently
able to edit transfer and upload videos
onto YouTube also damn that dog uploaded
the cat video in record time and it went
viral in record time
shaming just like finding Nemo and
finding dory the heroes find a way to
travel be a bird say what you want about
the students cleaning habits at least
he's got a diverse diet he's got Chinese
food fried chicken pizza hamburgers and
whatever the hell that is in the
blender bull you're saying that in all
of Williamsburg these two dogs smelled
only sausage and were led to some weirdo
hipster weinery with a terrifying mascot
also Weiner follows the eye before E
except after C Rule except in a movie
for children where they'll certainly
spell it the wrong way from now on
unless Anthony Weiner owns this and
that's a whole other set of sins I had
to count it but this movie is
challenging Batman V Superman hard for
the record for most dream sequences in a
2016 film also this secret life of pets
movie has time for a dream sequence
involving sausages but not one
conversation with these dogs learning to
be friends this phallic meat party is
making me a little uncomfortable can we
go back to the part where they were
swimming through raw sewage no candles
you gave ducky McDuck face 15 but you
can't give your beloved viperone
felt-tip marker penetrates a wooden
crate because that's the level of detail
movie is comfortable you gotta admit the
crocodile screwed everyone in the
scenario maybe just let the militant
bunny that can easily fit through the
pipe lead the charge for a change just
ignore what just happen it takes almost
an hour for the movie to devolve into
Shrek like poo jokes but it got there
you remember those assholes that the
other pets are risking their life for
yeah they're all cozied up in a sausage
coma in Brooklyn it takes nearly an hour
and sausage drunkenness to get these
dogs to have a conversation and there's
like 20 minutes left in the movie he was
the best Oh No she about to sing when
she loved me also don't do another dream
sequence don't do another dream sequence
don't do it damn it
by the time I had caught up with it and
ate it I realized I was so far away from
my home I couldn't find it
these dogs are the worst dogs to ever
dog listen I've seen homeward bound the
incredible journey and I know what you
assholes can do are you telling me these
guys after being assaulted by a rabbit
and
so forth earlier went to the hospital
got bandages and braces and then still
had to finish their shift how do I smell
well you've been swinging it around in
sewer water and sausages for the better
part of the day so I'm guessing not
great there it is
so these dogs can find a walk-up in
Brooklyn but not a high-rise in
Manhattan and if it were this easy to
find relative to the sausage factory why
the wood Duke not have found it before
now why did you bring me here max great
this is like a romantic comedy where the
guy does something stupid 30 minutes
before the movie ends and the rest of
the movie is that guy planning his cure
for cancer and/or saving children from a
burning building to get the girl back
only this time it's two dogs and they
just became friends for like five
minutes and the movie is over in 15 I
don't understand the animal control guys
seem to be willing to go to the ends of
this earth to track these two down but
now that they have won they're okay with
taking off let's see this is like
Frogger this is a dong so this is dog er
brilliant after credits scenes
advertising your next movie on a bus
inside the current movie is the new
hotness everyone seems only mildly
annoyed that this bus is causing
multiple wrecks and nobody notices the
rabbit at the wheel I'm not going to
even attempt to make my brain explain
how a bunny in a dog would be able to
hijack a city bus and navigate New York
traffic movie that began based in some
sort of reality has now essentially
become transformers I'm sure there were
easier ways to navigate the Brooklyn
Bridge like using the walkway but sure
walk on the cables this is the most X
MOC in a moment that is ever ex machina
how much did they get any information
about where max was let alone when he
would be there and there right on time
and ready to fight Jesus even Harry
Potter thinks this is a bullsh machina
how did buddy find the keys when he
didn't even need to know to look for
them in the first place and those keys
ended up floating to the surface nowhere
near where the truck crashing off okay
this is goddamn New York City but not
one squad car or helicopter is here to
address the major pileup on the Brooklyn
Bridge or the tragic van that went into
the river you think this movie meant to
spend as much time and the rivers of New
York City as it does did they get the
water guy from the good dinosaur and
realize they needed to get their money's
worth because the movies water game is
strong fun shot but even leaving out why
they would all come on this journey how
do they know where they're going I had
no clue just a few hours ago see you
guys home today owners he is such a
cheat a few moments ago snowball was the
primary antagonist that would
straight-up kill anyone that didn't
believe in the resistance now they're
not only helping them get home they're
ignoring everything that previously
happened in this movie
funny mom allows her child to capture a
wild rabbit standing in the middle of
the street without a thought about
rabies her militancy or anything sugar
here he can all walk right the hell back
into the apartments because all the
goddamn windows are still open also
apparently everyone in this building
also arrives home at the same time after
work but that's a crowded elevator okay
I think it's safe to assume this weird
relationship with his owner may be the
real reason sweetpea doesn't talk Pepe
is only in four scenes in this movie and
two of them feature him peeing moody's
parting message is if you don't have a
pet you're a soulless bastard that will
die alone the end and somehow I didn't
hear that music at all on my way to the
door
[Applause]
and if it's gonna come down to you or me
squirrel I warned you but did you listen
to me oh no you know all didn't you oh
it's just a harmless little bunny isn't
it
am I not totally enough for the turtle
club you know this bed is mine my name
is woody and this this is my spot see
the bed Oh what bite me rip my face off
let him do a little something first let
him do just a little something because I
want it I want this kid in my life
dogs and cats living together mass
hysteria hold your breath